*dramatic intro* and that creepy smile..
Hey, how's it goin' bros?
My name's PewDiePie!
Today we're gonna play "Ethan Carcher: Vanishing of Pewdiepie"
Um...
It's a game (duh)
We're gonna play it from start to finish.
And, uh, let's--let's go.
It's been a while since we've did a gameplay on this channel.
And "This game is a narrative experience that does not hold your hand."
I already like this game!
How about that?
I don't know anything about it.
So if this is shit...
I apologize....
Call on me.
Is it supposed to look like this?
*confused* ???
Whoa-oh!
Whoa!
OHHH!
OHHHH-OH!
OH!
K!
I may have over-exaggerated on the field of vision!
OHHH!
OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
I always turn up fie--FOV, like, max 'cause I think it looks good, but...
this is a game you can fuck with the settings, okay?
Alright! :D
That's a bit more pleasant, isn't it?
Okay!
Look at this!
So the reason I picked this game was because it looks fucking gorgeous.
*sniffs in forest air*
It's almost like you can smell the atmosphere
Can you smell it?
You're smelling your own farts.
Well, that's not my fault, okay?
Well...
Oooh! This game doesn't hold our hand.
Well, I'm just gonna go straight then
Fuck you game!
Can't tell me what to do!
Can I up the settings on the graphics even further? I mean---
Oooo, look at dat, it's so pretty!
I've seen screenshots of the game, but...
...whoa...
...that is...
...breathtaking.
It's almost like looking at myself in the mirror.
*sure it is*
It's so pretty.
*jumpscare* WHOA!
Fuck!
That's a trap!
Jesus asshole.
Why would you put that there?
*jumpscare* OH!
Fuck me!
*no thanks* i dont like this game anymore
*swoosh*
*smash*
OHHH!
STOOOP!
*jumpscare*
jävlar (swedish swear)
Stop with the fucking traps!
I can't
eugh *facepalm*
*fwoosh*
Oh, God, I did something.
[looks deep at screen]
Oh, great!
Ah, great, just fuckin' great, it's skulls everywh--it's skulls---
---skulls everywhere.
Guess we'll read it...
That is a good story!
That is a--
I really liked that story
I gotta say.
That was fuckin' scary.
I didn't like that. >:(
Yeah?
This bridge is not fuckin' safe!
Oooo!
I love the narration, it's badass!
Also, I dunno anyone else called Ethan but Ethan from H3H3,
and every time he's saying Ethan, I think of Ethan from H3H3.
*heh*
We're gonna find you, buddy!
Is it weird that I wanna jump off and kill myself?
It reminds me of Half Life 2!
Now that's a good game.
That's a game with unlimited FPS.
That game is so old! >:(
It still looks good.
Speaking of Half Life 2!
Where the fuck is Half Life 3? D:
I don't even care anymore, I've given up.
The meme is dead.
The game is dead.
It's almost like I don't wanna----
I'll take that back.
I'm sorry, I am so sorry. ;(
All right, well...
I think I'm going way too slow, I'm sorry.
Alright, "enter."
I think texts...
They don't look good
in games.
They need to sort that shit out, 'cause everything else is so pretty and then this...
...kinda like, standard ass font.
"crank shaft."
"fresh stratches."
"recently used."
*clang*
a--craaAAAAnk.
Crank! Uggh!
What is this, heaven rain?
Whoa! Oh!
Where is the crank?
Lemme enter.
Whoa. It's so detailed!
Is this i--in da game?
And if so, how the fuck...does it look so good?
There it is, okay.
There's the crank.
It's by the water.
The crank is by the watah, I repeat everyone
That's not too far away from here, let's go boys.
*smooch*
OH, CRAAANK!
Cranky croo, where are you?
Come here---oh! There you are!
Hapapap--
Padiepie!
That took ya fuckin' eva!
We got the crank...
...now let's crank back....
Someone cut the ties!
Untie.
Ooou!
No blood
Well, there was blood on the thing, that's for fuckin' sure.
Oh, that's where the fun went!
Blood trail.
Victim... Dragged away? Crawled away?
Severed legs
Ooou
Well, let's follow where they went...on their little stroll.
Hey, buddy, how ya doin'?
Ohhh! [x2]
You really don't have legs!
Cause of death...
Head trauma?
Touch
OH!
What? not yet? wHAT?
What is that...?
I can open, like, a memory portal, maybe?
I can't do it, though.
Okay...I guess we just, we keep going....?
There you go. *crank sounds*
Come o--
There we go, now let's ride our way home.
Wanna go home, everyone.
Yay!
This is the most fun...I have ever had.
Let's go this way
Fok it, let's go dis way.
I am having the time of mah life.
Excuse me, everyone!
I am the train conductor.
Toot, toot!
Oh, here's something.
Rock, rock, divot
Rock...okay...alright...a rock...alright...a rock....
That rock? What rock, this rock?
No not that one. :I
This---here somewhere?
Shh---all right, here we go.
Alright, I see something....
What do I see?
That's a rock right there.
Right by...
Okay, well that's good.
That---that made it easy.
That made it fuckin' easy.
Wh-ere you are!
We found the pa--
Eh, Pahdehpie, I love yah...
You took so long to find meh.
Did I do it?
Lemme touch you, buddy.
OHHHHH! [x2]
Okay!
We found all the clues!
Now let's see how dis mothafucka died.
Oh! [x2]
Are there----
Hell--How you doin' there?
Sh--ah, shit.
Oh God! :O
What?...Who are you?...What happened?
You cut off his legs, what dafuq is wrong with ye?
Eugh!
You--you fuckin' look at him crawl an' shit.
Well, let's go back, let's go back, let's go back.
What happened here?
The guy's like,
"Euugh, wow, that was not a good train ride."
Oh, they----put Ethan!
"I'm Ethan :D"
What about the stump?
What about the rock?
This guy saved us, maybe?
"Chronology."
What happened? [Alright... [x3]]
We gotta, we gotta set the numbers, okay....
neh, neh, neh, neh....
What happened first? What came first? The rock.
I don't fuckin' know.
Visualize!
Oh?
And then the old man is like...
I have a rock.
OH!
EUUUUUUUUGH!
Well, now we know how that happened....
Did I actually visua---put the right chronology on...?
Yeah, he's dead.
I did do it right.
How 'bout that?
How about dat?
Now what happens, now?
He comes back to life...I knew it.
Right back in his butt...where he came.
Oh--a fart.
Should I follow you?
Okay, I'll follow you!
You know what, I'll follow you!
Oh God, you're too fast!
Ah, shit--wait, it hit there? Okay.
Shit [x4]
I see it [x3]
There's another clue that we missed.
That's his grandpa?
The secret room!
I can't let you do that Starfox.
And we're back!
Okay, cool!
Whaaaat?
That really don't make no sense
Now what the fuck is this?
Hey! [x2]
Oh!
WHAAT?
What is this?
It's a fuckin' astronaut.
It's an astronaut.
Where you goin', Mr. Astrie?
Whadeh--what?
Astrie!
Where you go?
Oh I didn't---I didn't actually catch that.
Maybe up here, probably up here.
Astrie, I found youu!
What the fuck did he just--
*boom*
OHHHHH!
WHHHhhHHHhhhhHHAT?
Okay, this game just went fuckin' weird, what the fuck, how, are you smokin' right now.
Whaat? [x5]
You kidding me?!
HOOOOO!
OH!
Kay then, I suppose that's fine.
That's great---Thaaaaaaaaa---we're crashin'--
We're in space!! :D
We're in fockin' space!!
o-KAY then.
That's other guys chillin' in space.
How about that, huh?
Heya, how is everyone doing out there?
Ethan Carter here-
Ethan Bradberry, I mean, of course
Finding Ethan Bradberry: The best game of all time.
whAtt
*random noise*
Oh?
Well.
There was a note on the seat. *read*
"Fangs"
Oh my god the words are on the screen. I'm not doing this xD
And eh...
Ethan: GET OUT OF MY ROOM, TRAVIS!
Well..
That is..So sad..
"Gaylord."
So we wrote the story about the spaceman from
being inspired by science fiction.
Alright, well-
That makes a little sense. I suppose?
Alright.
That looks like a lil' uh, place we can go to. Let's-
Let's go there.
I honestly would not be surprised..
If fucking zombies comes out.
It has that Walking Dead atmosphere. I don't like it.
wha- Yeah.
MICHAEL recommended me the game.
So, if it's not good, go ahead and-
Shit on him please
I really like it so far though
I- Honestly, I tried out like 4-5 other games before this one.
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna stick with this one.
Look at that! It's awesome!
I hope we go in there later.
Well that was deep as fuck
Way to, way to out-deep my monologue
I played a lotta game before I found this one and a lotta them were just-..
Too narrative?
I guess?
And it just felt pointless of me being there.
Well, you can kind of play it yourself.
I suppose if you're watching me, you want to see how I react to it
Not just me fucking sitting back and listening to dialogue
I don't know
It keeps reminding me of Half-Life 2
Because I'm not taken away from the experience by loading the screens or like...
and it feels like, an open world.
Even though....
Fascinating
I really like... Okay I'll stop.
I'm sorry, let me hurry the fuck up
I'm just fascinated looking at everything
the atmosphere.. or tone changed
should we go back to the previous field of vision?
I wanna go to this house, I wanna see whats up
Looks like we're in the countryside of UK?
Is that a fuckin' tenticle coming out?
great it that kinda game, isnt it?
awesome
well i love a good tenticle.. what can I say
just don't tell Marzia
we are going in everyone
hello
lets read our first note
Okay.. Oh
*creepy sound*
that note had some OHHHH
THERES A GHOST IN THE HALLWAY! wut
I suppose we goin' in the gho- okay were entering like
The thing, right ... Oh
WOAH!
WOAH (x2) That door was not there
BEFORE!
What is this?
Mysterious...
*laughs*
OH! What the hell was that?
What is the swap thing?
WHAT??
AHHHH
Can we do that again?
It says swap.
Its says swap when i click on it.
Whats that mean?
*swoosh* [x5]
I can change the rooms!
*swoosh* [x6]
lets check the
Okay alright. Fuck that I'm scared.
Alright fuck you house
I don't like you
You can have your tentacles...
To yourself
What the fuck just happened
What is happening now
Fine
Tell me witch
Uh..
Poop
Diary
oh?
Oh shii..
Ya
Definitely on that one.
Ya I do
Why wouldn't I?
What the fuck?
I would say injustice in that one, thank you very much bitch
It comes from the mind!
It's like minecr---
Hey, I found your house
That's a cute little house
There is a witch. I knew it!
Oh, god
I hate witches...
so much
if there was... oh god
if there was a game called the witch
i would not play that game
thank you very much
Hey what wrong with a good fiction
k
THAs a lot of crying
thats 9 months of cryin bayba
OHHHHHH REKT
good story
i like that story
that was a good story
she live in here?
can you imagine going in?
there is just like
a - farting old ? la woman
being like
AY
WHERESMYCHESESBERGER
starting to understand this game
a lot more
you know uh
as we go along
i uhhhhhmmmmmmm
and how it plays
It's....
VERY VERY
different.
The thing is--
I thought
It was very story heavy
So--
As soon as
I started playing it
I kinda just--expected
the story to take place--
On itself,
but really youu--
--YOU have
to find everything
by yourself.
I know the game
warned me about it,
but it still grrogrengr caught me of guard.
I know I talked about it
A MILLION
times
We used to have a forest--
just like this--
JUST outside
my backyard
aaand..
It is not--
NOT nice to have it
in your backyard
'cause when it gets dark
and you look out in that forest,
it feels like--if the forest
is lookin' back at you.
Alright?
I don't like it
not one bit.
NOW I'm lost.
Lemme just find where I'm going. ;_;
...Alrighttt--
What...
Do we...
Have heree?
(A sudden sigh in relief)
Another house...
ok.
Graveyard.
Nothing wrong--
Just a bunch
a' dead people.
And me!
Hello.
THAAAAT.
IS.
A CREEPY-ASS.
Statue.
EXCUSEME?
Can-I-look-at-u.
just-to-make-sure
DAMN u look--
THAT'S JESUS! :DD
Hey man!
No--it's...
(Poods tries to read)
We're in Germany.
Or.
Something.
I think.
Ethan Carter...
Is such a German name.
Sooo...
'makes sense.
Alright,
We're going in.
This--
Abandoned church.
(Nervous sigh)
That's cool.
Glad we did that!
( sick beats)
The game that--
doesn't hold your hand.
HEYYYYYY
What's happening here, guys?
OH
We found something.
Finally.
Burnt matches.
Oil can.
OKAY?
Is that a clue
Or some
shit?
WHY.
STOP.
Are you sonofabi--(GASPED)
(coughs furiously)
OH!
HEY BUDDY
Buddy: HI Pootypie
Buddy: How u doin' buddy?
Buddy: I waited for u.
Buddy: Finally you're...
Buddy: DISCOVERED--
Buddy: The first--
Buddy: Secret.
Buddy: You dumb Bich
Buddy: Jesus Christ.
Buddy: The game told you...
Buddy: That it won't--
Buddy: Hold your haaand.
Buddy: And what did u do?
Buddy: U fucked it up.
Buddy: (Angry voice) You took FUCKING 30 MINUTES--
Buddy: To pull this
Buddy: shit off.
Buddy: Jesus Christ.
Buddy: Alright.
Buddy: I'll go with you.
Thank you Crow-kun,
You're my best friend! :D
You're my NEW best friend!
and I love u
I don't know what
I just did--
but--
I did it.  (clicks tongue)
And I am
Damn-diddly-proud
of it.
now we can't get down here, can we?
we can and it's scary
NOW, we can fix the crow
aaand we can pull the thing
aand let there be light!
OOOWWW!
what's the smartest motherfucker on this planet
that's me
tha-that's me
hey, how you doin' there buddy
yeah you look good
yeah, you look real good
BUDDY: hey, POODS  how you doin'?
you're dead
alright?
don't talk
another!
*BURP*
OW, god, that's disgusting
alright, i will take this
alright, well I think we got
what we wanted down here
thank you very much
dead man
and I will be on my way now
thank you, thank you very muuuch
walk anywhere
OOOOOOWW!
YOU F*CKING PIECE O'SHIT, LAMP!
I looked everywhere for you
I got the lamp
I'm going back
takin' my enemies with me
*poods language*
so they will never forgive me
Oil lamp you b...cunt
there ya' go
alright we got the oil lamp
we got the wheelbarrow
we're good 2 go
now let's see what's up
with you boy
wadap with you
boy
YEEAAS!
we are in
alright,
let's see your story
what happened
soo curious
about these little things
feels great
oh, you're gonna go there aren't you
no
there
you went there
ok
what do you got
there's a focking ant here[x2]
yeah that's right
alright, cool
that's cool
I think we've gotta figure out
the chronological order
I got saggy fockin' tits
alright, they walk first, right?
and the they were like ..... shit!
OK .... they still have the light here
or right here
Yeah, they have the light
all right, ok , all right
all right ,this shouldn't be too ha...
and she is like
well ma fockin' stab you then
because I got saggy tits
I'll just try it
poor
Dale,  man (fuck you dale)
well that failed
oh my god there's a  lot of stabbing
happening here and I don t know what I feel
about that
Now we got it!
we nailed it we, bamboo, we bame
babdo bo
look that house has a smiley face on it
look at it is so cuuuuute
oh my god that's the best thing
oh
well that's great
we did it
High five , that's.........
a worthy high five ,right?
Yeah, no, that's totally it
a little creepy this game man
*stutters* A little a little
Little spooky spooksy eh.
I didn't expect to be spooked out.
Heyyyy.. were you gonna go
were you. right there... ok
Dad i could fucking hear you fucking idiot
where is it then
I know where to go now
were going to the mines
of course
the next area
which i thought i would progress
to right away. Jesus Christ.
Well well well
Mr. cave
looks like i win
this round.. i shall
Just mind my head
right there don't hit my head
Wow we made it inside, everyone
ohhhh we are in  WE ARE IN
inside everyone
it is nice and moist and tight
and i like how it feels ohh
its soooooooo nice. i just want
keep going. can i plz
thank you. oh i see
i see something on the other side
what is that
Oh, we found
another way
another hole
well... any hole i will
find here i will go through
i will follow that light
*sniff* *sniff* smells a bit
weird in this one. I wonder where
their electricity is coming from. thats quite impressive
there an elevator in here
I'm gonna go down
thank you elevator
thank you
hate stairs
that would have been really a pain in the ass
wouldn't it
cyberbully ca- channels are cancer cancer cancer cancer (still relevant?)
ok where were we. oh yes the light.
i don't think
we will go here. it dark. it scary
dont like
if i have learned anything from this game at this point is that if you don't look
in every fucking area
you are bound to fuckin miss the whole game
apparently. ahh i
i see. of course
how could i have been so
HOW could i have been soo blind
embarrassing [x2]
wow this
place is cool
yea really this really is a mine
ohh
pickaxe rack an empty
slot
VHERE IS DAT
PICKAXE!!!
juuuust abouuuut here
i don't see anything
where is it?
ahh it must be in the
dark. We're not seeing very much too
what do we have here
up
ohhhh its
going... hey you were just
chilling in the water a second ago-
ohh i found him
mystery solved everyone
game over. ah thats not Ethan
ahhh shit i thought that was Ethan
alright well we found the saggy
titty girl. alright
you know you could watch literally anything else
but this right. just wanted to let you know.
ok I'm happier here
this is really going down a long fucking time
Jesus Christ man
Jeeesus
Dayum
Finally, we're- deh...
Well that's a lot of cozy candles
I wonder who set this up
Marzia
Marzia She wants me-
*strange noise*
Oh- that's a... that's definetly Marzia
*squeak squeak squeak*
Oh god
Oh
shit shit
Someone's fuckin coming!
*squeaking continues*
Hey!
OH!
NO!
No!
oh!
That's a monstah!
That's a monstah
*fwoosh* aHh!
WHA-?!
RAWR
Not fuckin cool!
(the face of someone who did not sign up for that jumpscare. aka all of us.)
You think you're so funny, huh?
What tha fuck
was that
shit??
The seal- fuck your seal
fuck you
fuckin seal you scar...face son of a
uh- that was too far
*inhale* God damn it
That must've scared you as well
that really fuckin took me, man
You play this entire fuckin game and then nothing scary
happens. I mean, a lot of scary shit happened.
alright this a map
there ARE jumpscares
I repeat
jumpscares
we best be careful
tread carefully
I probably should've followed that map but- uh- I
yeah no no, we're fucked now
Hey bud
How you doin? Not too good?
yeaya
that was...
freestyle
Oh- that's a gate of hell
and pain
Great <3
I- I feel like I might be going too f- uh
heyuh, how you doin' buddy?
Not too good? Okay great
*ghost breath*
Well I don't know what's correct
Hey it's you
*fwoosh*
RAWR
well well well
what do we have here?
oh?
wow
Well don't mind if I do
Does it still work? *click*
oh wow *engine sputters to life*
IT'S
MININ' TIME
oh shit
Well, I guess we don't go that way then
OHHHHHHHHHHHH
IT'S MININ' TIME
ooh that was cool...
wow
now what?
CY-ber bully channels are cancer, cancer
cancer
AYY we're going this way
*rattling*
Partaaay!!!!!
Aye Aye Aye
i've found somethung
Excuze meh
Excuze meh..let me get out
let me just......
i like this...thing ,this thing is great
IVve found the pickAXE!!...wahOo
so proud of myself
I wanna thank my bros
and my..hoes
You know who you are
Thank you very much,Thank all of you
*ghost noise* there we go pickaxe
and now i will touch you
OH that was it that was it
We just needed the fucking pickaxe
What a fucking joy
Alright
There we go
They all went upstairs. SHIT
No! They did not
Okay let's find out what happened
wat happened
he's like: I have a fucking pickaxe.
And a fuckin patterned shirt
hey bitch you better stay in this elevator bitch
eyy I got a fuckin ralph lauren... ah press the elevator
and then i was like i got a f*cking pickaxe again
this looked like the first one isn't it?
There we go, let's try this
it's never a raccoon
'probably a raccoon' does no..not exist
Thank you very much
That was fucking jumpscare monster all over again
oh well i fucked it up there didn't I?
that's a pretty brutal way to die
fuckin hell did I skip one?
I think I'm.. accidentally did that ughm sorray i didn't..
well, we'll solve the outcome
what about the sleeper
eheh then you first
Maam
sounds like a fuckin South Park character
well, good things happen.. in good minds (and mines)
wELL we're gonna keep going in this f*cking cave then
omaigawd
can i go here?
it IS a chemical reaction
I don't like it tho
I'm not going there yet
my guess is that we just have to --
-- find all the bodies
the bodies will help us solve the puzzle
we've found two bodies
found you
Anotherrr one
I think that makes four
mmkay
Let's try this
I'm not sure i got all of em
Okayy
They are all standing on the symbols
OHH Kay
Hey guys, I did.. Aww where did they just left?
What the fu-fuckin hell ah shiit
The thing is falling down
Ohh [x3]
CTHULHU [x2]
OHHH
What's happening
I didn't ask for this
Awww nawww
Fa.. F*ck the kid. I'm out- ah shit
There is.. no god
there is.. only cthulhu
I'm so sorray
Mr. Octopus
I was just about to
go in the.. complete opposite direction
..of where you were going
Mr. Octopus
I'm so sorry
please don't eat me
I want to read the story of Mr. Octopus
gnaaaaaaaAh??
gnaaaaaaah's
gnaaaaaaaaaAAH (okay that's enough now)
that's exactly what happened, Ethan
Bradberry
that's a great story
HOLY SH*T  its mean
I think we know [x2]
the last stop
we have to go through the acid, right?
Bubbly water is just fizzy water
is.. just.. fizzy water
dooon't you worry
eugh looks gross tho
can someone explain to me what the chemical reaction is cuz--
I.. I don't know
is this why my hair is blue?
I knew it
it looks like a lil froggies are vomitting
that's what I imagine back there.. bout what it looks like
is this a normal occurrences in caves?
ok you know what I don't wanna know anymore
I will go
Well.. [x3]
Something crashed the gates
For realsies
I guess we go out the same way we came in?
Crouching would make sense, thank you
Oh, cool ok, so we went down
remember we were up there?
Thats cool
We're back to the beauty of the game
look at dat
Absolutely stunning
Whoa
That is weird to look at
That is so strange to look at
I imagine a titan just fucking coming up
Thats the elevator
Fucking piece of shit-evator, it should be called
Asshole
Donut like you
Ah shit
Ah fuck
Well how do ya do poodiepie?
watch out, I might... stab you
Next. Mission
dache House
Ah! Found it
and.. we are in
Oh!
The axe is on the floor
Next to the  dead *chuckles* body
Great
That's great
I assume we're gonna find it h..here.. somewhere?
Oh here it is
Let's get you first
alright we just begin it with you, huh?
mmkay, that was one piece
next one should be the axe
then I dont know what to do
let's try him
maybe we're lucky
open (x9)
yESS!
Fuck yeah!
What happened to you lil buddy
what happened, huh?
you think you tough?
you ain't tough for shit
you dead
you.. gone
you'd missed
Alright what are here
That saggy fuckin tits' lover here?
well thats meee
how you doin
Yea that's right you like saggy titties
that's his.. dad
talking about his mum
that's her brother?
sister's son?
where are the other ones?
I got a f*ckin scissor dudee~
but I got a fuckin axe
but I got a scissor man
Came from the mine as well
Oh
Ohh
is that? I did get it right, huh?
didn't want her to get hurt so I killed her
don't run to the house if you want to die
Jesus
Great
Great, just fantastic
Really?
OHH
Ohh
Didn't expect that
What a meanie!
That is.. that is so mean to say to your dad
I would never talk to my dad like that
My dad is really cool
Although he's not put-a-scissor-in-your-throat kinda cool
He's just kinda cool, alright
Alright let's see the final thing
Where do you want me?
Where do you want me babeh
Am I a ghost? no, we're following the one
Ahh for fuck's sake
gotta go outside now?
fuck me, mate
so much walking in this game
my- my feets are tired
Jesus
Oh! now we can go in the house of course
Maybe we'll find ETHAN BRADBERRY
well I just assume we are going in here, I don't actu..
OHH the doors are opened the doors are opened
HALORHHH??
Hi poodiepie i waited for ya
My God
IT IS CHAIR
Mr. Chair: oh why don't you take a seat?
take a seat? right there?
poods: no chair, I can't
Mr. Chair: I see youuu..
poods: pls chair leave me alone
Mr chair: come take a seat, that's what you..
poods: SHADAPP
Cool machinery
Hah
Ugrhh
Alright let's finish this bitch... excuse me very much
I'm tapping x4
and I tapped out
thank you very muchhh
Did we close the dam? Damn
How did we get in if it was locked?
Mr. chair: Why don't you take a s..
Poods: NO!
God damn chair
This reminds me of a game that I played a while ago
elysium i think? or something it was called (captioner's note: it's called eleusis :D)
It was very similar; It was creepy, it was really a..
It wasn't really a horror game but it still scared me
aaand it was kind of puzzles.. 3D, it was very pretty
can we walk across now?
Wow, that is cool
I hope I don't fall down
this is so pretty i wanna live in this world
why can't everything be this pretty?
Vaiiiiiiiiii??
SO ANGRYYYY
The textures and everything is so great
kind of pretty well but, those grasses mannn
c'mon, that's not how rocks work
wooo
Whoa
is there gonna be a f-f-at plot twist in the end?
where Ethan's a sleeper and I am the sleeper?
at the same time?
oh, Marzia is calling me
very pretty new area
Gorgeous
was gonna stop
giving the game praise but
giving the game praise but,
it is incredibly detailed
it is just fantastic
how they created this.. thhis place
whoa, that's the house that burned?
wat happened?
must have been a nice house
They really liked lions back in the day, huh
Can't let you do that stuff, huh
ok well
I don't know
or... yeah
Did I do it?
OH! OPEN ZE GATE
Oh there it is, *laughs*
MAMA
MAMA IM here
shit, I'm too late
what did I do wrong?
OHHH well you want a ..
kiss, don't you?
Oh, ok
How you doin there?
Triple dot x3
What? I don't even have to....
Whaat?
okay
it's the grandpa, i guess he was last
Gasoline
HEY BOY I've got a fuckin gas
Yeah?
ok grandpa let's just move the table first
we could burn the table
alright let's just fuckin open the thing
I should be a story teller
Oh shit
That ain't no ordinary house
That's fucked up
Why??
Well i guess I will suffer
Oh no
What a dick move grandpa
HA! that wasn't much of a warning dude!
Now that is.. a chill way of dying
(chill... juxtaposed with fire... we get it pewds)
*awkward laugh*
Okay then
Well
Good talk
Where are you going? in there?
You gonna open for me? thank you.
Now what happened in the sleeper's room?
ETHAN BRADBERRY
OH! Mind blown -- I -- whoa
Stories? Am I part of the stories as well?
Oh okay. It will check off if we found all the parts of the story
Yeah we did.. I think we got 'em all
So we can tra.. Let's just travel then
That's nice like this
But.. I think I had them all
Wait, did I forget one?
How about that one
Yeah
I guess that starts our stories
I was part of the story
Cuz we were just like ..
he wrote us as a fan letter
just a famous
Whoa!!
Sleeper
Was us
All along
That's.. that's some real sh*t man
Wow, that was a .. unexpected ending
But I- obviously not very ..
joyful
But it was a good ending
I really liked it
That was good
What do you think?
I don't know
mmkay
That was The Vanishing of Ethan Carter
Haha, they call themselves that
Uhm
Yeah, I really liked it for --
-- why I found it, which was --
-- how amazing it looks like
Just like..
the detail of the world and- for it to be an indie game is really impressive
Uhm
Ya, it was a good game
I don't.. I don't
It wasn't.. It didn't like blow my mind
But I played in a day
So.. for what it was I think it was really good
and uhmmm.. I hope you enjoyed this as well
I'm glad I was able to do a more uhmm.. gameplay episode
for at least a day
Cuz it has been a while
Uhmm
I do wanna do these every once in a while
It's just I'm always waiting for games to come out
and that's kinda like..
.. the main thing if I'm not playing enough games
But yeah, this is fun
I enjoyed this, I hope you did as well
Thank you so much for watching
I really appreciate that
I think that's really cool
I hope you enjoyed it
Sharing this gaming experience with me
I think its a cool thing to share
Hopefully it wasn't too painful for me being a little bad at the game but..
I think it should be alright
and yeah, I'll.. I'll.. I guess I'll end it here
Thank you again for watching
and I'll see you in whatever next video
STAY AWESOME BROS <3